yeah the n-word the short answer is that
Maya could not stand the n-word had no
use for it and the context of its use
did not matter to her her thing was very
simply that if I have a vial with
crossbones and skulls on it and the word
Pio i som written on the bottle its
poison if I take that same poison and
pour it into the most beautiful Vaz of
Baccarat crystal ever made it's still a
poison for her the context of the use of
the word didn't matter now this is a
generational thing because Maya was
30-some years older than I am or was at
the time of us having this conversation
and my view of the n-word is a bit more
nuanced again based upon the generation
that I've been raised in and the music
that I listen to in the culture that
I've been a part of so my view is a
little bit more liberal than Maya's view
on the n-word and so we had this debate
for years about whether it's not you
know the n-word was something that ought
to be used in any context and we never
agreed on that there are a number of
things we never agreed on she asked me
when I was in Africa what I thought the
greatest virtue was of all the virtue
status which is the greatest virtue for
you and I said I think love is the
greatest of all the virtues and she said
I think courage I said really she said
yeah so for 28 years of our friendship
we debated which is the greatest virtue
love or courage her argument was that it
takes courage to love and my argument
was but-but-but-but-but love is courage
enacted I believe that love is the
greatest of all the virtues she thought
it was courage we never we never settled
that debate so there are a number of
things that we would come back to time
and time again over the course of our
relationship and we had different
opinions the point of this is that she
allowed me to interrogate her she
allowed me to disagree she welcomed my
opinion she wanted to hear what I
thought on a particular issue even if
she thought I was wrong we had debates
about the merits of art versus
entertainment and what makes something
art what makes something entertainment
so we had these debates all the time but
it was it was such a beautiful
relationship when we were
always allowed - to engage each other
and no matter what the conversation was
no matter how tense or terse it might
have been about a particular subject
matter every conversation always always
always ended on a love note she never
allowed a conversation to end without it
being on a love note